lab coat ripoff doctor strange
you know what you're right I could get
used to this magic stuff
people who are really dying don't keep
bringing it up is it true I don't know
I'm just usually around people that die
faster that's not how that's with you
know what this one counts as one of your
adventures Rick and Morty
five all-new episodes starts Sunday
November 10th at 11:30 half the season
you deserve all the season we could
handle 40 what did I tell you only on
Adult Swim welcome back everyone it's
Charlie big surprise they dropped the
brand-new Rick and Morty season 4
opening scene so we'll break it down
there's a whole bunch of Easter eggs and
guess which of the scenes are real and
which are actually scenes from episodes
we're doing a new round of that Rick and
Morty merch giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave
all your theories about which of these
scenes are real and which are fake on
the video even if you're brand new to
Rick and Morty and you haven't been
watching for a long time you probably
noticed that the order of fake and real
scenes has switched just a little bit
between season 1 season 2 in season 3 so
far so between season 1 season 2 in
season 3 they sort of switched up the
order which are real and which are fake
they used to alternate with a very
specific order for the first couple of
seasons that they switched up for season
3 no matter to the season they always
start with the season 1 scenes of them
opening with the equations in the
planets transitioning to Rick escaping
the monsters and leaving Morty behind
everybody grab your vouchers for one
free replacement Morty but then you have
the new scene of Rick using a breathing
mask to fly through the vacuum of space
without a spacesuit into what looks like
a giant chaotic space battle raging
between different factions while a
massive Cronenberg looking morty
destroys all the ships that get too
close to him he spins around looking
really pissed off then there's another
new scene of Rick Morty and Beth in the
garage next to Rick's spaceship
surrounded by angry looking cyborg
terminator snakes that look like they
want them until they're rescued
by a different Terminator looking cyborg
snake that's walking on two cyborgs legs
fighting all the other snakes off then
turning around to address them and
explain itself the reason why I think
this is another Terminator cyborg snake
is because its head is the exact same
shape as the heads of all these snakes
it's just that it
has cyborgs legs that is walking around
on then there's a new scene of Morty
hooked up to an IV drip and what kind of
seems like Rick's bedroom falling asleep
on his cot then he crashes into some
psychic barrier into another reality
where Rick is in the middle of getting
the crap beat out of him by some evil
looking shirtless scientist in what kind
of seems like a Flash Gordon
esque science fiction adventure serial
parody he's got a bunch of shiny rings
with different colored gems on his
gloved hands which is giving me Avengers
infinity war and endgame Infinity
Gauntlet flashbacks love the look of
terror on Morty's face here then there's
another new scene of Morty either made
giant terrorizing aliens at their beach
or is regular-sized Morty terrorizing a
bunch of tiny aliens at their Beach this
kind of seems like it's a parody of the
release the Kraken scene from the
classic Clash of the Titans movie then
there's another new scene of rick morty
beth and summer all in the kitchen
running from a two-headed goose that's
chasing them revealing that rick has
modified the refrigerator to be a backup
weapons storage locker he grabs one of
the weapons and gets ready to shoot the
goose they've shown in many different
episodes but primarily in season 3
episode 6 when he's fighting toxic Rick
that he has weapons hidden all over the
house not just in the garage where his
workshop is then they always end with
that same scene from previous seasons of
them flying away from Cthulhu who's
trying to destroy them for stealing baby
Cthulhu still waiting on that Cthulhu
episode that they keep joking that
they'll do eventually so if you watch
some of the previous trailer videos that
I've done you've noticed some familiar
footage in this so we already know for
sure that at least one of these scenes
is real but a good clue is following the
pattern from season 1 season 2 and how
they change that pattern to season 3
opening scene the season 1 opening scene pattern was in just basic alternating
fake and real scenes so it started with
the fake scene of Morty falling and not
making it through the portal the real
scene of Jerry vs. the bugs with the
shotgun that was from Rick potion number
9 there's the fake scene of Jerry
finding out about robot Morty then the
real scene of Rick's struggling fighting
the family with that Nintendo
cartridge that's from the opening of
meeseeks and destroy' there's the fake
scene of pregnant Jerry the real scene
of them being saved in anatomy Park and
then the fake scene of Rick Morty and
summer escaping giant Cthulhu so it was
just basically fake real fake real fake
real season two was a similar pattern
you start with the fake scene of rick
drilling into the dining room being
chased by the mole people
then the real scene of rick's sending
more tea during look who's purging now
in their Iron Man suits the fake scene
of Rick trying to figure out a science
problem while Jerry almost gets it,
the real scene of Rick and summer pillow
fighting with mr. Beauregard from Total
Recall then the fake scene of all the
different Rick's working together they
changed the pattern of fake and real
just a little bit during season three's
opening scene though it starts with the
scene on a world where everyone's faces
are butts with butt face Morty getting
caught looking at rub hub then instead
of alternating to a real scene it's
another fake scene of two different
summers working together to infiltrate
the Galactic government facility with
Rick then it alternates to two real
scenes the Morty's escaping during tales
from the Citadel during their standby me
parody then the real scene of Rick and
Morty almost getting piano man
concerto here being saved by Jaguar at
the end of pickle Rick and the end
credits scene then it alternates back to
fake with Rick shopping for a
replacement Morty at the more tea store
so which is alternating to fake scenes
to to real scenes back to fake so taking
those changes into account early
prediction for season four opening scene
order is the space battle with
Cronenberg Morty is fake the Terminator
space snakes scene is real because we
saw a totally different Terminator
parody seen in the last trailer with
those snakes a lot different from season
three we've got a lot of a lot of
shoot-'em-ups a lot of lazer
shoot-'em-up the scene of Morty falling
into the dream world might be fake the
scene of Morty going all cracking Morty
might be fake making the scene of Rick
vs. the two-headed goose reel so
everybody leave your predictions about
which of these scenes are in season four
episodes in which are fake but for those
of you hoping for that Cthulhu episode
there's actually a clip of Justin a
couple years ago explaining what their
plan is that they're all meant to be
technically real scenes but they just
won't get to
episodes till way way later on the
opening credits there's a lot of seeds
that look really cool are those in their
future episodes future episodes you
ready here first
it might take til when Justin's son is
doing the voices but we'll get to so at
some point it sounds like they're
planning on paying that off and because
they have the 70 episode order it's a
lot easier for them to slot those things
in if you look at the giant box here
this is them closing down their season
for writers room transitioning to season
five stuff the picture there be story
generator just shows you how many crazy
ideas they come up with
but because season four episode one is
premiering Sunday night my full video
for episode 1 is going to post Monday
mornings so as long as you have alerts
enabled for my channel you should see
that when I post it what if it makes us
run faster jump higher okay let's eat
the baby all of my episode videos will
post on Monday mornings but I will be
doing bonus videos throughout the week
and trailer videos leave all your
requests if you have any specific
questions I know everybody wants to know
what's going on with evil Morty I've
already had a chance to see episode 1 so
I did a non-spoilery review of that I'll
add a link to that at the end of this
the season is as good as ever
I know a lot of people were worried what
was going to happen to their creative flow
between that giant break and then trying
to get that 70 episode renewal but for
those of you that are worried that
they're going to end the show after those
70 episodes are done the way they talked
about it they're optimistic that they'll
go way beyond that but I don't think
that it's realistic to expect them to go
as long as something like The Simpsons
or South Park as much as people would
love to see something like that it's
just really really hard to keep creative
levels up for longer than say like 15 or
16 seasons right now the 70 episode
order gets them to ten seasons assuming
they do ten episodes per season but let
me know in the comments how many total seasons do you think Rick and Morty will
go do you think they'll go beyond ten
will they make it past twelve or fifteen
I'll name a new giveaway winner when I
post my next Rick and Morty video every
click here for my early non-spoilery
review of Rick and Morty season 4
episode 1 and click here for that last
really big Rick and Morty season 4
trailer video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight